hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
show in this video we'll consider good
memory editing become mainstream so that
the that's that that's that do you
remember the 21st night of September do
you remember the lyrics but would you
want to forget ever hearing my song well
I hope the latter isn't the case but the
silence of memories continues to be of
great interest and has played major
roles in a variety of pop culture
whether three memory enhancing drugs
such as the limitless or selective
memory removals such as in men and black
or The Incredibles but whilst love may
change the minds of pretenders can
silence be used to change the minds of
patients one day will it be the norm to
raise the memory of a bad date say or
used therapies it leads all to a
traumatic experience but what actually
our memories are they even a single
entity although I enjoy the creative
representation of memories in the Pixar
film inside out as each being collected
in glass pools memories are just not
like that now I'm not a neuroscientist
expert but I am still a scientist and I
was curious to investigate this father
say from reading a bunch of literature
mainly from this recent nature a few
articles should you check out I will
attempt to evaluate by the memory
editing Kurt's become mainstream so what
are memories so memory is the glue that
holds our mental life together strong
statements but it's true memory is the
process of retaining reconstructing and
retrieving information that allows us to
add meaning to everyday life but what
actually is a memory and how was it
stored say memories can be split into
two categories declarative and implicit
so decorative memory refers to facts and
events people's names definitely
actively wants to remember so it
includes the item that you'd want to
learn for an exam implicit memory is
retention independent of conscious
recollection so that was some kind of
fancy phrase and it basically means it
includes perceptual and motor skills so
often people think it's includes knowing
how to ride bike but both these
divisions come
my father set up the key point is that
different regions of the brain are
required for these different types of
memory so neurons presence and these
different areas are responsible for
memory formation and to memory is the
strength of connections and activation
of a specific set of neurons that also
depends on the changes in patterns of
gene expression and protein synthesis
the more active a memory is the stronger
the connections but memories get lost
over time when these connections weaken
and so connections between neurons
otherwise referred to as the synapse is
our thoughts thoughts are formed the
basis of memory and depends on the
strength a number of connections made
between neurons neurogenesis the
production of new neurons may also play
a role but less is known about this at
the moment but the bottom line is
different types of memories can be
stored in distinct brain regions so say
we want to alter the memory of an event
well the complication is that a single
scent can include different forms of
memory and therefore they can be encoded
in a variety of places and expressed in
different ways so the example given in
the review paper is recollection of a
car accident this one offense includes
episodic memory of when and how the
offence happens defensive responses to a
visiting the location of the accident
I've had bitch'll responses to avoid
that area just to name a few the point
is is that editing the memory may
require the modification of all these
areas separately which could be
advantageous allowing specificity to
memory editing but also a
disadvantageous juice the complications
it creates but how would you even be
able to edit specific memories so one
idea for targeting specific memories is
to do it when the memory is active as
this may enhance the search process and
hence specificity of the editing also if
you're going to edit a memory the memory
also needs to have forms and so based on
what is known about memory formation
there are two vulnerable windows where
modification could take place
consolidation and very consolidation so
consolidation refers to the initial
storage of a memory whilst
reconsolidation refers to memory storage
after retrieval so as you can see by the
graph these two different stages have
different time frames where they are -
label almost prone to modify
Asian and say targeting after the
initial encoding may provide a larger
time frame over which to carry out a
procedure for memory editing making it a
more desirable option at the moment but
would one of these areas be more
effective than the other who knows
so what methods of memory modification
to be even have so one methods is to
mimic or block the effects of hormones
so stress hormones appear to enhance
memory consolidation you may agree that
it's easier to remember an emotional
event than a neutral one say by
mimicking or blocking this hormonal
effects memory could be strengthened or
weakened the next method is spatial
therapy and so this could be used to
learn that the stimulus that was once
threatening is now safe and so this is a
form of extension learning so what
happens is the subject is exposed to
what was the threatening stimulus but
with no offensive consequences said the
affection associated with the memory
becomes extinct but it's not clear if
the new memory competes with the old
memory or the old memory disappears
another method is targeted memory
reactivation so this is quite a nice
reference but I distinctly remember
watching episodes of my parents are
aliens ads of kids where Josh one of the
main kids in the show played this like
audio recording bossy slaps to help him
remember for a test so them maybe
century from this as memory
consolidation is thought to involve
recurrent free activations a process
that Kinsella car when we sleep say with
the right cue targeted memory
reactivation could become an effective
strategy to enhance memory formation
another way to enhance memory formation
could be very behavioral tagging so this
doesn't well sustain its currently it's
effectively enhancing a memory by
tagging it to a stronger neural pathway
so I say chasing it with a memory that's
already more active and so the last
method as for you about is imagery risk
Krypton so this involves getting the
patient to
the outcome of a traumatic event so
that's it is now non traumatic so the
offender's affectively Reptoids so one
day you may be able to rescrub some
events so that you came first place in
the race instead of second place
okay so haven't gone into too much
detail about these different methods but
that is partly because the mechanistic
underpinnings are not actually fully
understood yet
moreover many of the tests conducted
safe have been done in animal models and
so you translating them to humans would
be another like major hurdle to face so
you know with these methods even be
effective in humans but why would we
even want to be able to do this well
it'd be cool obviously the joking aside
there are many valuable clinical
applications of memory editing should it
become safe non-invasive and effective
for example it could be used to prevent
cravings from drugs to high-fat foods
and preventing post-traumatic stress
disorder and also for enhancing
education well and for raising memories
of alien encounters of course but will
it become mainstream well as you may
remember from Incredibles - if you've
seen it's that dhikr refers to memory
editing as not being an exact science
mainly due to the issues that he has in
specifically altering the memories of
interest he actually raises too much we
can see that in terms of the mechanisms
and the methods were not there yet and
even if we did get the results that we
wanted we don't exactly understand how
or why we made it happen
but with the hype already surrounding
memory editing in pop culture and the
current knowledge that we already have
sure
memory editing could become mainstream
the key question is one